YORK.
HERE'S TUCKER.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
A PRETTY SAD STORY TONIGHT.
ONE PERSON IS DEAD.
THE ALLEGED KILLER MAY SOON
BE ROAMING THE STREETS FREE.
WHY IS THAT?
WELL BECAUSE LEADERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE
STARTING TO BELIEVE
INTERNALIZED BELIEF, ACTED
ON THE BELIEF THAT ILLEGAL
ALIENS HAVE MORE RIGHTS THAN
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
LOOK AT THIS PICTURE.
THIS IS EYE VON CASS TENANT
THAT.
THAT IS AN ACE OF HEART
TATTOO ON HIS FACE.
THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM WITH
THIS MAN.
FIRST HE IS ILLEGAL ALIEN.
SECOND OVER THE WEEKEND IN
DENVER POLICE SAY HE GOT
DRUNK AND SLAMMED HIS CAR
INTO A SEMI-TRUCK.
THE TRUCK BURST INTO FLAMES.
THE DRIVER WAS BURNED TO
DEATH.
RATHER THAN STAY AT THE
SCENE, HE FLED THE SCENE.
HE WAS LATER ARRESTED.
NOW HE FACES CHARGES OF
VEHICULAR HOMICIDE.
AND THEN POLITICS GOT
INVOLVED, WHICH IS WHY WE
ARE BRINGING THIS TO YOUR
ATTENTION TONIGHT.
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES HAVE
ASKED DENVER TO DETAIN THIS
MAN SO HE CAN BE ARRESTED ON
FEDERAL CHARGES AND DEPORTED
BACK TO MEXICO WHERE HE IS
FROM AND SHOULD BE LIVING.
BUT, NO.
THEY CAN'T.
WHY?
BECAUSE DENVER IS A
SANCTUARY CITY.
AND THAT MEANS THAT
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS THERE
ARE COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
THE ACCUSED KILLER EVEN IF
IT MEANS HE WILL SOON BE
LOOSE IN DOWNTOWN DENVER AND
HE MAY BE.
AS SOON AS HE POSTS A
$25,000 BOND, HE WILL BE
FREE TO GO UNTIL HIS NEXT
COURT DATES.
THAT'S ASSUMING HE BOTHERS
TO SHOW UP IN COURT AND BY
THE WAY WHY WOULD HE?
HE SNUCK INTO THIS COUNTRY,
IS HE GOING TO GO TO COURT?
PROBABLY NOT.
WHEN DEMOCRATS SAY THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO PROTECTING
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS,
THIS IS WHO THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY BELIEVE ILLEGAL ALIENS
AUTO COULD YOU SEED OF
MURDER DESERVE TO BE
PROTECTED FROM YOU MORE THAN
YOU DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED
FROM THEM.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT IVAN
CASTENATA IGNORE FEDERAL LAW
ON HIS BEHALF.
WOULD THEY DO THAT FOR YOU?
I DON'T THINK SO.
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS HAS FILED SUIT TO
STOP INSANITY LIKE THIS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS SUED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A SANCTUARY STATE THAT
HAS EXPLICITLY ANNOUNCED IT
WILL PUNISH CITIZENS THERE
FOR COOPERATING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN THE
PURSUIT OF ENFORCING
IMMIGRATION LAW.
DEMOCRATS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
OUTRAGED BY WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS DONE.
THEY ARE CALLING HIM THE
REAL CRIMINAL.
WATCH.
>> JEFF SESSIONS SAID IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
AND I CALL UPON HIM TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BRINGING THE MENDACITY OF
WASHINGTON TO CALIFORNIA AND
TRYING TO INSERT DISCORD AND
DIVISION.
>> HOW DARE YOU VILIFY
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY BY
TRYING TO FRIGHTEN THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC INTO
THINKING THAT ALL
UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS ARE
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS.
>> Tucker: HOW DARE YOU?
THIS IS HOW THE LEFT HAS
BEGUN TO THINK.
IF YOU BELIEVE ACCUSED
MURDERERS WHO SHOULDN'T BE
IN THIS COUNTRY OUGHT TO GO
BACK TO THEIR OWN COUNTRIES,
YOU ARE THE ONE WHO IS OUT
OF LINE.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN BORDERS